Vowels...
We use them every day, but how much
do we really know about them?
In the English language
we have five specific vowel letters,
each with its own unique personality.
First off on this linguistic A-list
is, well, it's A...
about as popular and versatile
a letter as you can get.
A balances representing an impressive
seven different vowel sounds
with the glitz and the glamour
that comes from being the
English language's very first letter.
A is literally the alpha
of our entire alphabet.
It's the highest grade a teacher
can give you for your work,
we have A-list celebrities,
and many of us grew up watching
The A-Team save the day
on a regular basis.
Some scientists believe that A has an
entrenched motivating impact on us,
and can improve performance
at work or creatively.
A is quite playful.
It features in a lot of words
that are just, well, fun to say,
like llama, aardvark,
handbags,
balaclava,
Madagascar, jazz hands,
to name a few.
And A isn't too interested
in numbers either.
If you spelt out every number
from one upwards
you wouldn't be using an A until
you got all the way up to 1,000.
E, in contrast,
is much more grounded.
It's the only vowel
in our most-used word - the.
And it's also the most-used letter
in our entire alphabet,
appearing in 11%
of all the words we use.
It's the second most likely key
to break on your keyboard
from overuse.
E is essential to storytelling -
it allows us
to write in the past tense.
When E is left to its own devices,
it takes a deep interest
in the natural world...
endlessly green elements,
stems, trees, weeds, levees etc.
I is very concerned
with its appearance.
It was the first letter to receive a
dot when in its lower case form
and it's the only letter that is
always capitalised when on its own.
It's also the first word in the
shortest complete sentence
in the English language - I am.
It's great for active verbs,
and when on its own,
it appears in a host of words
related to excess and desire.
Without it, you couldn't have
kissing, or drinking,
or hitting, or spilling,
or hardly any illicit thrills at all.
Out of all the symbols
we use for vowels,
O is the one that appears
the most in other languages,
even ones that developed completely
independently of each other.
The shape of the letter O
mirrors the shape of your mouth
as you make the sound,
and it's thought that's why
it appears in so many
different languages.
This constant circular shape
with no beginning or end
offers some of our
most mysterious words...
things like the moon,
spooky howls,
grottos, horror,
ghosts,
groans, moans
and bones, too.
U is much more scientific and,
partly due to its
lateness in the alphabet,
always has one eye on the future.
It's an abbreviation for university,
for uranium,
and is linked to submarines.
It provides us with some
pleasant words,
but also some of our
most unpleasant ones.
U also works well with other letters.
It can be completely silent
when it wants to be,
and it can be rare to get three
vowels together in a row,
but when it happens,
in most instances,
U is in there
holding it all together.
So there you have it.
The English language's vowels -
essential to everyday life,
each one packed full of personality.
You'd best learn to live with them,
because you can't speak without them.